Mexican brother I ask you to plant a
tree that you take care of your nature that
take care of your mountain that you take care of your river that
take care of your water that you take care of your food
we are brothers all follow house pot
cash this
Canadian is American is this
continent the other all are the
brothers, I do not care if you always
mexico in europe in asia where the
Always going to help the environment
Well, nothing happy because we are going to go
the honeymoon to plant trees with
children and then the idea is to continue
with this project I am very excited
because motive against wind and tide
did the project I think the trees
they belong to everyone
yes